début de matinée c'est christophe métais
informaticiens paris la semaine et
week-end il revient en touraine dans la
maison de famille pour vivre sa passion
le karting handicapé de naissance
pratiquer ce sport était un véritable
défi est une prouesse technique
comment vous est venue de l'est du
quartier bas c'est ya une piste 17
ouverte à la ville-aux-dames ya plus de
plus de 15 ans maintenant
et puis j'ai commencé comme ça en
loisirs et le l'ancien propriétaire a
revendu et j'ai rencontré xavier
champions qui lui manu petit à petit à
la compétition d'une famille de
passionnés d'automobile quand même un
oui oui tout à fait ouais ouais j'aime
beaucoup les voitures j'aime beaucoup la
vitesse et samassa m'a amené là quoi
votre baer collectionneurs votre moment
oui mon ex maire aussi au 8 août a fait
ce jeune quadra donc été élevé dans un
univers de course automobile et de
collection de voitures anciennes
son père disparu c'est sa mère qui
aujourd'hui suit avec une certaine
fierté ses premiers tours de roues en
compétition
c'est à vous que je les admire à tenir
ouais ouais
quelques fois je me dis oh la la il en
fait trop mais bon c'est lui c'est mais
c'est vrai que je suis très fier de mon
fils oui ou non engagé à ne jamais
jamais plus tôt même encouragé et enfin
je mets à n'ont jamais jamais empêché de
faire re ce qu'il avait envie de faire
donc ça mais mon mari a au contraire lui
était peut-être pire que moi et ils te
poussent et un est je pense que c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que il fait
maintenant fin de matinée arrivé sur le
circuit de la ville aux dames près de
tours c'est une école officielle de
karting de la fédération française du
sport automobile
cette école est beaucoup plus pour lui
c'est une rencontre humaine entre une
équipe mais aussi un homme au nom
prédestiné il aviez champions son coach
pilotes mais aussi son aigle son
mécanicien
c'est une dizaine de personnes qui se
sont mobilisées pour son projet et qui a
adapté ce carte 4 temps spécialement
pour lui donc l'adaptation pour un an 10
cartes en fait on supprime les pédales
bien sûr attendait un cap à l'usagé au
niveau des jambes tout le système de
freinage d'origine reste quand même sur
le karting on s'amuse pas à le démonter
et après au niveau du volant on insère
donc de deux palettes une palette
d'accélération qui tire l'accélérateur
qu'on voit bouger de là bas au niveau du
moteur et une palette pour le frein donc
c'est un freinage hydraulique avec le
maître cylindre qui est carrément inclus
au niveau de la palette donc apprendre à
usage d'un carrasso tout à fait
classique en accélérant éclat main
droite et en freinant avec la main
gauche
voilà ce n'est pas sans une certaine
émotion que christophe roule sur ce
circuit qu'il connaît comme sa poche
c'est là où j'ai commencé là où j'ai
appris à bouger mis des mots sur ce que
je faisais parce que ta vie' al diplôme
de moniteur de karting et il a même pu
mettre des mots sur ce que je faisais
alors comment j'avais que la théorie
moi j'avais que la pratique mais pas la
théorie et sa mine de rien ou même en
ayant la pratique ça ça apporte beaucoup
d'avoir la théorie est de savoir
exactement ce qu'on fait ça permet de
perfectionner ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'il faut travailler
les trajectoires les freinages surtout
c'est ça le plus difficile de toute
façon en sport automobile
ce qu'est le plus dur c'est de freiner
ce qu'il faut freiner fort et faut que
ça soit efficace sans perdre de temps
xavier est un ancien pilote mais aussi
un gentleman driver commandes méticuleux
et attentionné il suit circuit après
circuit les progrès de christophe avec
la tendresse d'un confrère rôles forts
rôles forts donc est ce qu'il a ça dans
le sang
pourquoi pas hein
peut-être que papa a transmis le virus
aussi un petit peu je pense beaucoup
même
et effectivement il arrive à être
performant il fatigue il fatigue comme
tout le monde mais finalement il à la
résistance pour tenir toute une manche
les compétitions se déroulent sur un
week-end complet donc c'est quand même
très très intense mais il tient le coup
et le coach aussi
et
non
début d'après-midi circuit de ville
perdue en indre et loire
on monte en gamme et en puissance cette
fois ci c'est le vrai kart de
compétition 1 5 centime étude de tentes
christophe a été aidé par la région
centre val de loire et par là et ce cas
de loches
il participe avec les valides au
championnat régional de la ligue du
centre voilà c'est la belle histoire de
christophe comme pour reprendre ce que
la vie ne lui a pas donné
c'est